pizza
is this thing on i think it is
so uh i'm erin cohen i'm one of the
professors associate professors
in d mice the department of medical
informatics and clinical epidemiology
and the director of commercial
partnerships and collaboration or maybe
it'd be easier to say i'm the director
of the
informatics discovery lab so welcome to
another informatics discovery lab
industry leadership talk these are talks
that the
department of medical informatics is
sponsoring as part of our
informatics discovery lab initiative
um what's the informatics discovery lab
initiative you might ask
well what this is a new initiative of
the department to
really focus more outwardly i mean i
think we
always focus on important health care
problems but we're not necessarily
focused on
you know what to what to do with those
solutions how to get them out into
to the world and what that takes
so the mission of the ideal is to really
increase both innovation and the impact
of that innovation by
increasing industry partnerships which
will help us deploy some of these
innovations more
broadly we've got a number of strategies
including collaborative research and
development
the establishment of non-uh traditional
educational opportunities
developing a more entrepreneurial
culture around informatics and
healthcare innovation which is kind of
why we're here today
i just wanted to mention a few of the
initiatives that are going on right now
in the idl
number one is a predictive analytics
service which is headed by
dr david dorr the vendor visits an idl
talks such as this one that we're having
right now
we're looking into the expansion of the
internship and practicum programs
much more broadly both in terms of
students and also in terms of
the kinds of opportunities and
really educating the ohsu community both
informatics and outside the informatics
community about
entrepreneurial skills and topics and
that kind of
is why we're here today you might ask
why
is uh tech transfer giving us a talk
in the idl leadership series and and
really the
issue is that how do you be an
entrepreneur
in the informatics world how do you get
your things out there how do you work
with industry well tech transfer is
really the uh group at ohsu it's tasked
with
helping innovators get their ideas out
of the research lab and into the real
world
of patients and providers and
manufacturers and healthcare systems and
soft healthcare software system
providers
and so today we have our guest andrew
watson who's the director of technology
transfer
um in business development at ohsu
and he's going to teach us what we need
to know to effectively use the resources
of tech transfer and business
development
to be more entrepreneurial ohsu
and this will help us achieve our goals
of becoming a more entrepreneurial
culture becoming informatics
entrepreneurs and widely
deploying our innovations out into uh
the real world
um so i just won't have one last thing
to say because i always forget to say it
so i have a note here push the button
right so andrew's going to talk for a
little while then
he's going take questions uh these
sessions are recorded
so please when you ask your question
push the button so the little red light
is on unfortunately have to hold it down
and so your question gets recorded along
with the answer because a lot of times
the answer makes more sense if you know
what the question
is so with that i will turn it over to
andrew
and thanks for coming
thank you thank you aaron thank you for
bill thank you
debra for the invitation to talk today
um i brought two of my colleagues from
technology transfer and business
development with me
um who you may know uh but they
work directly with you
because they're assigned to your
department so
they're going to come up here as well at
different parts and give a little deeper
dives
into the aspects of the they handle um
within technology transfer and business
development
and feel free to i want this to be an
open session
feel free to ask questions at any time
what i want to do is give you an
overview of technology transfer and
business development here at ohsu
some of you may have worked with us in
the past others maybe not
and you might not know all that we can
do for you all the services we can
provide and
so we want to get more engaged with what
you're doing here
in the department so
um what is our department
what what do we what do we do um
ohsu research uh drives discoveries that
improve health care create jobs
expand the economy improve quality
quality of life okay
so one of our primary goals in
technology transfer and business
development
is to bridge the gap between promising
research and that
that could be basic wet lab research or
the research you do here in
in in d mice and we want to move that
out of the unit out of the walls of the
university
so it can benefit the public that's
that's our number one goal
and and we could do that a number of
ways we could just publish everything
that happens here
and just get it out in the public domain
that's getting it outside the walls of
ohsu
otherwise we can work with industry and
that's what my department
really is good at and and does day in
and day out is partnering with industry
because industry will then develop the
products and services that will
solve solve problems salt it will come
up with a solution for a problem
so to reach this goal we need your
participation
we are weak we are only as good as the
ideas
and the interactions we have with all of
you
so we we can't do it alone we need your
help
we need your input so
for those of you that don't know i'm i'm
not quite the
top of the food chain in technology
transfer business development we
uh do have a vice president for business
uh tech transfer and business
development it's dr
timothy stout he's also a practicing
clinician
here at ohsu he's a pediatric
ophthalmologist at kci
institute and he also is a researcher he
has his own
fairly well-funded research lab at kci
institute so he sees this from a lot of
different angles
both from the basic research the clinic
and working in tech transfer business
development to bridge the gap
between those two
so why what are some of the reasons that
you may
work with our office think about that
but here are some of the possibilities
developing a new technology protecting
your unpublished work
you know are you wanting to generate
more lab departmental funding
collaborating with outside researchers
seeing your research or idea become a
product or service
meeting the obligations of a research
contract many of you if you have an nih
funded
grant or contract or any other
research project there may be
obligations in there that we actually
have to help out with at the end
closing out the grant um
protecting new discoveries and starting
your own business
um there's maybe some of you that have
an idea of
well i want to have my own business at
some point some point based on the
research based on the work i do here at
ohsu
we help facilitate that we spin out
anywhere from two to four
new companies a year out of ohsu this
past year we spun out two
just for trying to forecast the future
i'm guessing that
by the end of the upcoming june we may
have half a dozen companies this year
that are spun out of ohsu so um
we're we're trying to do this more and
more and the university
is very supportive of entrepreneurism
and starting your own business
so i want to give a little the structure
of
our department we've got primarily
five different work teams work groups
within the office and you may interact
with those groups at different times
for different projects so we have an
industry and academic collaborations
group that i will let trina vos talk
about a little bit later
we have a technology development and
licensing group
on the far right which arvind peranjpe
who you've many of you probably worked
with he'll
talk about that a little bit further we
also about two years ago two and a half
years ago we formed an in-house
patent team we called a patent team
because that's primarily what they do
is is draft prosecute maintain
patent protection on intellectual
property or new ideas
discovered here at ohsu but they do work
with other forms of ip
protection that being copyright or tr
and or trademark as well
so we can get into that a little bit as
well if you want
again this is a more of a high level
overview
but there are reasons and arvind will
probably talk a little bit about this
especially with things that happen in
this department
of patenting versus copywriting and
especially with software
so we can get into that business
development so the
other part of ttbd the bd
is business development business
development was
formed about six years ago
to have two primary roles
uh well well originally one role now
they've
have a second primary role the first is
to
increase industry partnerships
with between ohsu and outside industries
so we want to be
looked upon by the industry
community as a partner that they want to
work with they want to come here to
portland
find out what's going on in the
laboratories here
and work with us and that could be
collaborating that could be funding
research here
that could be forming a joint venture
that could be
you know licensing technology from us to
put into their product pipeline
so a variety of ways that we can partner
with industry but we need to have those
initial interactions to see if there's
any chance of forming
interactions with that industry partner
so our business development does
that the other major role that they've
taken on in the past year
is our startup company program
they are still in the process of
revamping this but we're
putting a more formalized process in
place of
trying to educate those that are
interested in starting a company
as well as helping our companies after
they're launched
and maybe after they move out of the
walls of ohsu
whether that's hooking them up with
investors that come to us
asking us you know we want to look at
your companies in this space
we can we can showcase those companies
we help hook them up with management to
help run the company
we may know if they're needing fda
advisors for for
federal approvals we may know
consultants that we can
help hook them up with so we try to help
them as long along
both pre-launch and post-launch
because if they succeed ohsu succeeds
because the technology that they're
developing gets
closer to being out in the public and
for public benefit
um and then really supporting all of us
is our
administrative services group of finance
marketing communications uh folks
in the office so we um
you know we've tried to do a a number of
new events
recently we are i think some of you
maybe attended
um arvin's brown bag session last month
on uh software patents and licensing
uh we have that every other month
a different topic every other month we
have quarterly newsletters now going out
so we want to tell you all that's going
on with
what we do as well as what are some of
the changes happening in the world
around technology transfer around
intellectual property
big change earlier this year in patent
law the largest change in the last 60
years or so in the united states
so we want to let people know what
what's now changed what's different than
it was
a year ago so we want to get
communications out and that's
a lot of what the administrative
services group helps with as well
so one of the questions i know we're
asked a lot a lot and i know from
talking with
deborah and aaron and bill uh earlier
was you know where when when and where
do you contact us and what do we what do
we do where can we help with so
what i what i want to do is this is a
probably a rough
um schematic timeline of
a process you may um
take on in your everyday practice from
having
a research idea to
well now i need funding to carry out my
research idea so i
i get funding i do the research so all
of these first sections of having a
research idea funding
and then carrying out the research we
have at least two groups that can help
in different aspects of that
business development they can you know
they if you've got an idea
they can maybe hook you up with industry
or other partners that
can help with funding for that there's
many
non-for-profit uh organizations that we
also help
connect our researchers with there are
also
internally within ohsu a number of
research consortiums that our business
development group has now formed across
the campus
one of these groups is in pain um
you wouldn't imagine how many
researchers across the university
deal in some aspect of pain who didn't
know each other
who didn't know what the others did so
this was a way to connect those
researchers within our own institution
so that they could now and many of those
groups have been successful at writing
large collaborative group grant
applications together
so we can help with funding we also can
help with funding
on the industry side introducing you to
industry partners who have a need they
have a problem
and maybe we have the solution or maybe
we can come up with the solution
but we have the expertise here at ohsu
that can
fill that gap for them and that's that's
where we try to fit in with industry
is we want to hear what their needs are
and we try to fill those needs if we can
um and then industry and academic
collaborations group they may
they deal with if a company wants to
fund you they will
they will do the agreements and i'm not
going to
steal trina's thunder but maybe you need
a research material
for your research so they'll do a
material transfer agreement
or maybe you want to collaborate with a
group up at university of washington or
at
portland state university and you want
to protect
your ideas that maybe you know don't
that
you share in that collaboration well
we can put together a collaboration
agreement we do this quite often with
other research institutions
as well as industry there's no money
changing hands
maybe there's some materials but it's
really an exchange of ideas back and
forth and it protects both parties
interest to publish it kind of spells
out okay who's going to publish
when um protects
any intellectual property that's
developed if there's new software
developed it'll it'll
carve out and and spell out how
all those aspects of the collaboration
will work between the parties
so going down the continuum after when
you're doing your research maybe you've
got a new
discovery something new you've
discovered something that solves a
problem
a solution to a problem well that's
something
and i'll let arvin talk more about this
but that's something you you
may want to likely disclose to our
office
which we can then um assess further
decide whether there's protection needed
um
if we do pursue those angles we then try
to move it out of the university
through marketing mechanisms licensing
and we
manage those license agreements after
they're done
so this this whole process really is
handled by the technology development
licensing team which arvin is your
representative from that team for this
department but within that there are
other groups in our office that handle
different
parts of the process as well when we get
a new invention
disclosed to our office if there's
federal funding or if you've received
funding from
industry partner we are required to
disclose that and report that to that
sponsor
whether it's the nih the dod
or company x
uh you know from the protection side our
patent team may
get involved whether it's registering a
copyright
or drafting filing a new patent
application
and also our from our marketing
licensing side if if we're doing a new
startup
company formation arvin will be working
with a member of our business
development team to help with that
startup
formation okay at the end goal if we're
successful in this whole continuum this
is what i would call the technology
transfer
continuum if we're successful
there's royalty income that comes back
to the university
so that's our finance group within the
office handles
how that royalty income is split and i
can go into how that's split if you're
interested
but it's it's shared between the
university
um these uh defined units within the
university and then the inventors or the
creators
of that invention okay
so that's the whole process now what i'm
going to do is go a little bit further
in depth on
very specific aspects of that so i'm
breaking out
different parts of that continuum so you
know
where when how we can help you okay
so our business development group again
they support ohsu's commercialization
mission they can help foster academic
industry
partnerships and alliances and they are
one of your
primary liaisons between industry and
ohsu
if you're having conversations with
industry someone probably from our
office should
at least be there to make sure we're not
giving away
anything and we're helping to protect
you and the university
so our business development team can can
participate in that
and they help from the very beginning to
expand the commercial potential
of researchers and centers here at ohsu
so again at the very beginning of the
stage you have a research idea
how am i going to fund it is it time to
partner with industry early on
um if you you work with
products i imagine from industry all the
time from companies you probably
purchase them
well you often discover well they have
flaws
so is there some way to improve that is
there some way to improve that software
is there some way or
some way to improve that device well if
you do
or maybe if you have an idea before you
disclose your
solution to that problems before you
disclose your solution to that
flaw in the software hardware you might
want to get us involved
so we can help protect that
idea and work with you on the
appropriate way to interact with that
industry
partner because oftentimes you'll just
disclose this improvement
to the company the company will just
incorporate in their materials and not
tell you anything about it
so great thanks okay
so um business development
can help in the early stages
and also while you're okay go ahead
you have an idea like short of making
your own version of whatever that
software is and selling it from scratch
as a company i mean
what would what would you guys what
would you be able to do
um like do you go to epic and say hey
epic we have an idea how to improve
the screen and epic says great let's pay
you for it i mean how how does that
really
i'm gonna get to that later later but if
it's an improvement to an existing
product
that's often what how it works it may be
a small
incremental improvement or maybe a large
improvement
but it's something if the party that has
you know this product and this little
improvement adds additional value
to their product to that product and
future sales
they might want to incorporate that and
and what we would do is
want to license that improvement to them
so yes and we do that
i would say quite frequently
here you want the microphone oh sorry uh
so the first question the first question
would be
how do you go about protecting that
intellectual property
so if there was a way that we could
if it were something patentable then and
if a company would be interested in it
that's the best mechanism because then
it's the hardest for them to practice
without
our permission or in other words without
our license
if it's if it's not patentable then in
theory they can design around it they
can recode it
right if your software is written if
it's
somewhat complex and you're saving them
quite a bit of time to get a copyright
license so that they can start
kind of two steps ahead by taking your
software and modifying it or just
translating it into another language
then
that might be the best mechanism for
them
i mean actually it's good that steve
mentioned epic because
um i believe that our um
our cust our licensing agreement with
epic
as their customer i think explicitly
turns over all intellectual property
that's um uh created and i i guess to
generalize the question you know the
comment or question is um what uh
um aren't a lot of these um kinds of
issues sort of protected by
um the uh business arrangements that
that we as users have with those
companies
some of them are and some of them are
not and i think
arvind can get into this a little
further it depends on the
agreements or license agreements i think
that accompany many of these products
with epic
over the last few years there have been
some improvements to epics or add-ons to
epic that have
come to our department and our way
to this point epic hasn't been
interested in anything
so yeah i you know i think if it's
if it's a huge substantial change to
epic's
platform uh maybe they would be
interested and i don't actually know the
details of
ohsu's agreement with them
actually i believe our epic license
means we have to turn
some things over to them but not
necessarily everything
so so that's actually an interesting and
very
timely point because we have some
ongoing discussions
with epic and part of what's come up in
these discussions is that they're very
interested in their customers especially
their
academic customers
being more innovative and pushing the
boundaries of their product
to to
you know to to invent in a way and so
you know knowing what inventions we have
to turn over to them
for free versus what inventions we could
mutually benefit from
is is kind of a big deal um
and also it would inform us
i mean i i think specifically with epic
because they're such a you know
gorilla uh i don't mean that in the mean
sense i mean in the big sense
um that they uh that may
change the way we discuss things with
them if we know that everything we're
going to develop we're going to turn
over with them
in any way then maybe we want a little
more support up front to start to
invent some of those things and target
some of those things if that's not the
case
then you know we may be willing to put
in our own effort and then
you know reap the benefits later as they
license these things so it's kind of an
important particular you know context
that we kind of need to know more about
specifically the informatics
yeah and that's something honestly i'm
not going to say i i know what the
language of that agreement is i know
my counterpart at itg probably does um
because they're
more in um engaged with
that process but um no that's something
i think we we should definitely find
that out yep yep
yep yeah
okay um
so i'm going to turn it over to trina to
talk about the next couple slides
because this is uh the group in the
office that she works with
i'm not going to say anything further on
that
okay so if there's anything i hate more
than public speaking it's microphone so
this should be fun
anyway uh my name is trina voss i've
been at ohsu for about two and a half
years working mostly in
well in this group on sponsored research
agreements
non-disclosure agreements and uh
material transfer agreements
for that i was at usc working much more
in the licensing so i can
make comments whether or not you want to
hear them or whether or not andrew wants
me to make them
on a lot of what we're talking about
today like epic
and one thing i'd like to point out is
that this group has a huge advantage
over a lot of the departments here
at ohsu when it comes to commercializing
because what you guys do
is very focused you see problems you fix
problems
you're not coming up with some little
tiny detailed chemical that's going to
have to go through a lot of steps to
commercialize
so don't be thinking that you know we're
health and science and you guys don't
get all the attention
because when it comes to
commercialization you guys have a big
advantage over a lot of the groups
so what we do what i specifically do my
group does
is we work when you guys are trying to
get research materials
a lot of the time we talk about material
transfer agreements because somebody
wants a chemical or a mouse or something
like that
but we also do them for software and we
do them for data sets
so if you need software data set it
really really helps to come to us
and talk to us about it because you know
as well as i do that you can sneak it in
the back door
you can just send your stuff out it's
probably a lot easier than coming and
talking to me
but if you sneak the stuff in or out and
then you come up with a brilliant idea
that's when it gets sticky because we
may not own what you invented
because we forgot to do the right
paperwork on it so it's much better to
do it up front
another thing that we work on is
industry sponsored
research so sometimes that's an amazing
idea
that you guys are going to really love
and it's a huge project and
going to be a huge leap forward in
science and sometimes there
shall we say not as academically
interesting they're smaller projects
but to be honest they pay the bills so
if you guys are completely funded
and you don't need any kind of sponsored
research that's great i'll be happy to
leave you alone
but if you guys are looking to get a
little bit more money into the labs
and do things that you're really good at
and that have
some academic interest that may not be
your dream project
then i can work with you on some of that
stuff too
another thing we do is research
collaborations in general
there's no money tied to these but it
may give you access to data sets it may
give you access
to other researchers that you want to
publish with it may give you
opportunities to
to do some really amazing work i'm
always a little bit
leery about research collaborations with
industry
not saying they're bad sometimes you can
get great things but every now and then
you see ones that come through
and we're doing an awful lot of work and
they're getting an awful lot of value
out of it
so we want to be careful to make sure
that
if they're getting most of the value
that they're going to help fund some of
it too
another thing that we do is we help
protect ohsu information
so if you're going to be talking to a
company or if you're going to be talking
to
another group and you've got this really
great amazing idea
come and talk to us and see if we should
protect it first
we can do a simple two-page cda
confidential
i always mix up the words on that one
it's a confidential disclosure agreement
or a
non-confidential it's a cba or an nda
non-disclosure agreement they mean the
exact same thing the words are almost
exactly opposite
and i can never keep them straight it's
a really simple agreement
we can get it signed it doesn't take
that long it will protect us
if all of a sudden the company has this
amazing idea that looks an awful lot
like your amazing idea
because we can come back and show that
it was ours
so that's pretty much everything that's
on that one
okay so for last year this lab had one
non-disclosure agreement and the ones
that i work on are not
specifically for technologies so if you
have a disclosure and you have this
great invention and you tell our company
about it
you tell our office about it and you
want to go talk to a company then arvin
is going to take care of those
agreements
they're virtually identical it's just
how we separated things but we had one
non-disclosure agreement where we were
just kind of
generally talking to a company about
future projects
we had one sponsored research agreement
that's actually a no cost extension
that's just a fancy way we write it that
means we're working on a project we
didn't finish it up
we did again a really simple agreement
it was one page it didn't take very long
and it allowed us to continue the
funding so if you're working on an
agreement
and you're almost done and you you're
running out of time and you've still got
money and you're not done
come and talk to us because that's
really easy to get taken care of
and we had three material transfer
agreements the year before that we had
one non-disclosure agreement and three
sponsored research agreements before
that we had
three mta's and two sras so we've had
about
four or five agreements every year for
the last couple of years
again this is a kind of lab that has a
really great chance
to do more sponsored research agreements
so sponsored research agreements
they put money in the lab they put
projects they give people projects to
work on
some of them are amazing and spectacular
some of them
may not be as spectacular but we always
reserve the right to publish on them
you don't have to do them i'm not going
to come to you and say you've got to do
this agreement because i've got to get
signed off to make my boss happy
so if you want any help with that come
and talk to me yes
so one thing that's related but you
haven't touched on is do we ever
license our data to someone else yes
i mean there's a couple of different
ways to do that
and it depends if it would fall to arvin
or i depending on a lot of things
who is it going to if we're sending out
data
to simply another research institute we
would probably do it in a material
transfer agreement or do it in a license
and call it a material transfer
agreement
if it's something that we find is
particularly valuable that not many
people have
and that we want to have more control
over what the other group's doing
we might do it more as a license and
there's a chance of taking our data
and actually licensing it to a company
and bringing quite a bit of money
but we always have to be very careful
with that because we have to make sure
we know where the data came from
we need to make sure it's ours we didn't
get it in on an mta or sneak it in the
back door and forget to tell anybody
about it
and we need to make sure we've got the
permissions to pass it on
because anytime you're talking about
patient data you've got to be really
really careful to make sure that we're
not violating those patients rights
any other questions
okay excellent yes
with this data thing so you mentioned
like corpora
or other kinds of data sets if a data
set is publicly available like on the
internet the
you know such and such you know like the
i don't know
such and such linguistic corpus and it's
just on the internet to download and we
with with some sort of license about you
know copyright whatever university made
it but you can use it for your research
is that something we need to every time
we download one of those we're supposed
to tell you guys about it
or no okay but every time you download
it
if you make a copy of that license that
you download it with
you'll make my job a lot easier and if
you come to us and say hey i built this
great thing
and remember to tell us that you built
it on this corpora
especially if you can give me a license
the license that you downloaded by
that will make our job much much easier
and arvin is going to talk a little bit
more about what you can or can't use
but anytime you bring something in just
hold on to the paperwork for me
anybody else
i um let me see if that makes too much
noise
okay my name is arvin pranche um and
that's
actually a great question because that
is a good segue into what i'll be
discussing which is
let's whoops i don't see my slides there
there
okay um which is you know permissions
when you receive
something could be data it could be
software generally i'm talking about
software though
you can imagine three different types of
licenses
very high level you have the free and
open source
software license right you have a
permissive license
and you have lastly proprietary licenses
the free and open source
software license is actually uh there's
a lot
of obligations sort of written into that
those licenses and those are referred to
as copy left licenses that's the middle
box there copy left permissive that's
the
that's uh that type of license places
the fewest restrictions on you
the recipient so if you receive software
under an mit license
or the berkeley software distribution
license those are considered
permissive licenses you can modify that
software
and distribute it you wouldn't have to
go back to the original
author and ask them for permission you
can
in and actually just following along for
taking the first
box so that means you can as far as
downstream from you
you can send it out well let's just
imagine okay
so let's say you are in that middle
column
and you want to to create software that
you wish to
license under a permissive license if so
the only software you can incorporate
and modify
must be permissively licensed to you
if it's copy left and then you try to
license it downstream under the mit
license that doesn't work
they're not compatible um similarly if
it's proprietary so if it's if you broke
open the
microsoft word code and and you uh
you made a derivative work well i'm sure
in the terms of use and
the license agreement there that
microsoft had with you
they didn't give you permission to make
derivative works and so
you can't distribute downstream
taking the second box down copy left
let's say you want to
create software that you wish to license
under a copy left license so that's free
free and open source software license
examples are the
the um gnu gpl
the pharaoh gnu gpl the ferro gpl
the lesser gpl these are all
copy left licenses if if so
then the software you can use to
incorporate that you can
take and modify that's the left side of
the
of the column there you can take
permissively licensed software to you
and copy left they're compatible so if
you took a you know agpl code and then
you downstream you
you modified and you created some
software your software you license under
a gpl that's fine the stuff that you
took has to be licensed under an agpl
you have to provide those
notices in your license and that would
be all right
downstream from you all recipients must
keep
that copy left so they can't
they can't modify it and then license it
under any other terms
and then the last one down below the
middle column proprietary license so if
you wish to
create software that you want to um
provide restrictions on on users and
recipients well the only software you
can incorporate is
under a permissive license and then
downstream those downstream users cannot
make any kind of modifications
so this is a very brief
slide deck that i have here and i'm and
it's probably going to
create a lot of questions in your mind
and we'll try to get into
q a and talk about different licenses if
you have questions
i did not actually i decided against
focusing on the
the intellectual property protection
decisions of when we go
with a patent when we go with a
copyright license only
um and if you have questions we can find
slides and try to get through that but
what this
slide here is trying to do is it's
trying to give you an example of
what happens over time there's a very
long lag period
um before a technology is actually
commercialized
um so so what happens here so as far as
patent law goes an invention is
something that is conceived as
conception that that means
an idea and it's reduced to practice
otherwise it doesn't rise to the level
of an invention
so at the top here conception you have
the idea
it may or may not be reduced to practice
it's close though
you provide an invention disclosure to
us that's all those yellow
chevrons are our office being involved
the top
three blue ones are you um
we received that invention disclosure we
i don't know why it's showing up over
there
oh okay
um okay so uh
we would we would work with you to to
try to understand
two things patentability commercial
viability
patentability that has to do with things
like non-obviousness utility
and um novelty those are the
those are the metrics those are the sort
of things we have to get across
in order for it to be patentable on the
viable commercial viability side
we're asking questions like what is the
product what's the market what's the
competition
we would work with you to understand
that
if the dollars on the viability
commercial viability side
are great enough to justify the risk in
paying for the patent costs then we will
go ahead and
and file it also has to be of course
potentially patentable so so if it meets
all those then we would file the
provisional patent application
um during that time period if
you know we would want to beat your your
publication or presentation with our
with our filing and and then during that
time period
we would expect that you know you'd be
presenting on this idea you may
do further validation of your of your
concept
we want to get proof of concept in and
within one year of our provisional
patent application filing we have to
make a decision
as to whether or not to continue
to to pursue patent rights or not
patent protection is very expensive
there's these
dollar signals here dollar signs and
they get bigger and bigger as you go
down
the timeline small dollar you know think
think one to five thousand dollars for
provisional patent application
pct patent application think five to ten
and and nationalization well
that's we haven't gotten to it yet but
nationalization think
on the order of thirty to fifty thousand
dollars per country
very expensive so at each stage of the
game we're trying to
make a rational business decision
whether or not we should
continue on the process so
if we did file a pct application what
that means is it's a patent cooperation
treaty
patent application which is like a
holding tank we reserve
the ability to nationalize into a very
large number of countries essentially
all developed
countries and and virtually all
developing countries
throughout the world and um
what's good about it is that it puts off
the nationalization decision
for another 18 months once we file that
pct we
still have another 18 months and that
that means we are
um delaying those costs gives us another
it gives you another 18 months to
hopefully get
further proof of concept and
me more time to try to get a licensee
i'll be you know communicating out to
potent to companies to try to license
this technology to them
towards the end there of so that would
be the pct application
i'll explain the ndas in a second um
at this time of the go no go decision
when we're trying to decide what
you know what countries to to file our
patent patent applications in
hopefully we have a licensee on board an
exclusive licensee that will pay those
patent costs
and they will be the ones driving the
decision saying yeah our market
is the us and the eu and china
and everything else we don't care about
and yes we will we will pay you back
within 30 days of
of invoice so go go in those countries
and we'd be happy to comply
however if we don't license it by that
time then it puts us in a
sticky situation where we have to decide
where are we going to try to obtain
rights and where are we going to
forego rights
generally speaking the our office
follows the um
the policy that if we don't have a
licensee in place and it's at this stage
of the game
we are going us only we have to
we have to keep our costs low and
the us and probably the majority of the
cases is still 50
of the market so we're getting 50 of the
market with one patent application
um it's hard to beat that now as far as
the specific dates and and the title
here
this has to do with an actual license
that we
executed in um in july of this year
it is a software for oct
optical coherence tomography it is
was created by ricky wang and
it leads to extremely sensitive
vasculature images of the eye
useful for determining the health of
the retina and choroid etc so
we license this to zeiss it's in our in
our license agreement we have the
ability to disclose that
normally we have to keep that under
wraps as to whose licensee but here we
can
disclose we license it to zeiss as far
as the timeline goes
um
let's see here we received an invention
disclosure
and filed on it within
a month so we actually had very little
lead time you can see here
so we received the invention disclosure
january 2010 the next month we filed a
provisional patent application
normally we would need more time and
mistakes can be made if that happens and
we'd ask for
uh two or three months of lead time
before you're gonna publish but
but ricky told us that we're gonna he's
gonna be publishing we worked very hard
to get that
patent application in um
12 months later we not we um
sorry we filed our pct
and then um
we filed our pct and that gave us
18 months right here 18 months
to try to try to get a licensee and we
did enter talks with three
oct companies we had our
our pitch for why this was a valuable
technology
it would open up markets to their high
sensitives their um
to their higher end
oct machines only the higher end oct
machines would be able to get this type
of detail
so it's kind of like a selling point for
their very expensive machines
out of the three companies zeiss was the
one that that
continued to stay interested we tried to
not exclusively license it
to all three of them figuring this would
be the
best way to bring in the most royalties
as well as
get the the product out into the public
space
but the other two declined and
we were able to get the license
agreement in place but
notice the discrepancy so august
2012 we needed to have that license in
place and we didn't
and it was almost a full year later we
actually did the license agreement
so that put us in a very difficult spot
where we tried to decide
what do we do do we just drop everything
and go us only
i was able to get zeiss to commit to
some dollar amount
at this stage of the game in august and
that
helped so that kind of bought us time
and then during that
um so because we see that upfront
payment
um we had enough money to kind of go
ahead and file in the countries they
requested
and um sure enough we were able to get
the license in place
any questions regarding sort of the life
cycle of
sure
so i was wondering whether the timeline
varies significantly by
type of product that you're you're
patenting
um medical device versus software for
example
yeah great question so there's there's
the
life cycle of um commercialization
which will depend quite a bit on you
know whether it's software medical
device
compound biologic um and then there's
the life cycle of patent protection and
commercialization from
our standpoint okay this isn't getting
it out into the like
to to users so that like as of this date
users are not
getting scans on their eyes they still
have to go through the whole fda thing
it's going to take several years
for them to actually get this out in
clinics um
probably around the order of about three
or four years but as far as
the patent life cycle it's all the same
because these are all
prescribed by statute as to
when you know when this provisional
expires
how long of a holding time you have when
you file the pct
patent application that sort of thing
you're welcome yes aaron
so roughly speaking how much
does you know the licensing value have
to be to make it worth
going through at least to the u.s
only patentability i mean what are we
talking about here so if we were to
assume u.s
only uh total patent cost of
let's say 15 000 then
it should be greater than fifteen
thousand dollars okay
and um and then and then and then it
passed that you know i'd say
what are we looking at you know are we
looking at this thing
is definitely we're definitely gonna
license this it's only gonna
maybe bring in somewhere on the order of
twenty thirty thousand dollars
or twenty to fifty thousand dollars but
we'll definitely be able to license this
at least once perhaps a couple times
versus wow this might be a home run
we don't know chances are small but it
might be like
bringing in a couple million dollars a
year so it's all based on
risk and and what you expect as far as
return
risk and return analysis
no risk is going to oh risk is sorry
probability probability of success
and return so probability of success or
sum is going to be very small
yeah yes
okay is there any specific timeline
between
the provisional patent application and
the pct
for timeline between the provisional
patent application pct
good question so generally speaking it's
12 months
but not always sometimes you want to
file the pct
earlier based on your publications so
it's
it's a case by case
uh let me see if i have another slide oh
yes okay so i have this
this example so it's another it's
another example of a software that we
licensed
and um
got only about five minutes okay left um
we can go through another licensing
example or
go hit some of the high high points on
our involvement in startups and
you know royalty sharing thing other
things of ttbd
um what's maybe of interest in the last
five minutes or so
yeah i'd like to hear about the royalty
sharing policy okay
okay go for it oh okay
all right so um
so this was another example um
that arvin was going to talk about um
and also another device here
that ohsu has successfully
commercialized
the startup process this is again from
the chart earlier
with the business development group
being involved in startup formation
they helped to support the faculty and
launching these startups creating and
providing resources
for you if you're interested in starting
up a company so
we could have a whole seminar just on
starting up a company
there's a it's a real
different endeavor if you've never done
it before there's a lot of things you
probably don't know and that's what we
we try to let you know up front what
you're getting yourself into before you
really
take that that that leap
so then administrative services group
again handles a lot of
different things for our office one
thing they do which is on that
continuum is the royalty income sharing
so ohsu has a royalty uh distribution
policy
um roughly
if a technology is successful it breaks
down to about a third
goes to the inventors a third goes to
what are defined units at the university
that being school of medicine school
dentistry
school of nursing research development
administration
the hospital i might be missing one or
two there
the idea is that money the the money
that goes to the unit is hopefully
shared with the department or
departments
that helped fund that researcher or that
those inventors creators to help
money flow back into back into research
to i'll show you a chart to really keep
the continuum going
the other third is held by ohsu and
currently
that's used to fund a lot of our
operations in ttbd but
that could always be pulled and used
other ways by ohsu
it's a complicated formula uh the first
of the first fifty thousand we bring in
forty percent goes to the inventors and
then the other is split between the unit
and ohsu
thirty thirty of the next fifty thousand
so up to a hundred that fifty to a
000 is split uh 35 to the inventors
and then trying to figure out the math
and then it's
split between the unit and ohsu the
remainder part
yeah so if you if you invest personal
income or the departmental income
something like this
would that be recovered first before you
start to split royalties
no the only under policy the only um
the only financial resources that are re
um i guess what we call recoverable are
patent expenses um that our office
undertakes or if it's a copyrighted
material and we
register the copyright with the
department of commerce then that's
that's recoverable off the top but no
the
department funds are not recoverable off
the top
there are some alternative ways that we
can try to do that but
it's not looked upon favorably by others
in the university
really for tangible materials if we're
if we're set and uh my background is wet
lab so if we have
a tangible antibody that we put in
you know the lab put in five thousand
dollars to create that
antibody and we're just providing that
antibody out
um to end users not directly to a
company that's then is going to sell
but directly to the end user and we want
to recoup some of that
r d money from the end user
we often can bring money in and then
share all of that with
the lab and we call that a product fee
but that's really when we're sending it
or licensing it to an end user
and then beyond a hundred thousand if we
bring in beyond a hundred thousand
it's
30 percent to the inventors and then the
remaining 70
is split 35 35 between the unit and ohsu
so inventors get more at the front end
less on the back end over time it's
roughly a third a third a third
okay so again
this is the whole continuum
we could keep talking probably on
different aspects of it and we'd love to
come back and
you know drill down to certain areas
that maybe are
of more interest to all of you but this
is a whole continuum
at the end of the day you know we hope
that that royalty income from those
discoveries from that technology brings
that royalty income in
and shuttles back right back to the
beginning and starts the process over
again
so we want that funding that money to be
put back into the research engine here
at ohsu
and keep the new ideas and new
discoveries
coming through so that's that's our end
goal is
to do that but also get these
technologies out of the university
um so i'm not going to go through this
is if you're interested
look for this article from july
we put this article on research news
blog
here at ohsu this is a inventive postdoc
she just we had our annual awards night
last night she
received the new inventor of the year
award from ohsu from our department
her story is is very interesting because
it was a post-doc who had a problem in
her lab
and she developed a solution for her
basic research
problem that that solution
has now been licensed out to a
uh you know substantial uh research
uh tool company called clone tech
and um products is on the market now and
being sold worldwide so
you know it doesn't have to be the next
blockbuster drug it doesn't have to
be the next blockbuster diagnostic this
is a
you know basic researcher had a problem
in the lab
solved that problem and that solution
now
is is um you know
being this it's the solution now used
worldwide by other researchers
um and then the other thing is is we
have
back in april we released a
comprehensive guide
to everything we do so a lot of what
i've described is
is in written form if you're looking for
some late night reading
i have some copies here
feel free to take one otherwise we do
have it up on our website
which is really just search ohsu tech
transfer you'll come up with our website
it's up there as a pdf that you can
search you know learn
go really more into the patenting
process and what's all involved there
which could take you know half a day to
really describe
so that's that um
other news uh events i just have to put
a plug in for these we have a quarterly
newsletter that we started in june the
next issue will be coming out
hopefully next week we give updates on
what's happening at ohsu in terms of
technology commercialization
entrepreneurism
etc as well as what's happening in the
world what's happening in the nation in
terms of
legislation law changes that are
affecting what we do
if you're interested in starting startup
companies or starting your own company
our second annual startup symposium is
october 10th it's a full day
the first part of the day actually i
have that it's changed
the first half of the day is at the old
library and then
the second half of the day is at the
door and becker bay auditorium so if
you're interested in startups or
maybe not even but want to learn more
about it it will be an
entertaining and informational day
and then as i mentioned arvin did a
noontime brown bag seminar on patents
uh software patents and licensing
last month our next event is is later
october
on how to pitch to industry so you know
what you do in your lab
you know your research you know what
your capabilities are
now how do you pitch that to interest
industry in what you do
so that that's going to be led by our
business development group
but really you know i don't want to say
it but you know how to sell yourself
how to sell your research to industry
partners
okay so that's about it um
again we can we'd be happy to come back
or trina can come back and talk about
mtas all day long or arvin can talk
about
the patenting licensing process more in
depth
we hope this was a useful
overview of of where we can help out in
the entire
research continuum from
you have an idea what do i do now how do
i get funding for that idea
to now i've got an invention
let's see if i should protect it or not
that's what we're here for to help you
help make that decision we don't expect
you to be able to make a decision oh
yeah
this is something i should copyright or
this is something i should patent
that's what we do day in and day out so
we want you to work with us
and and feel comfortable calling
emailing us and
working with us okay
thank you
you